[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today all right
today's question comes from Jason and
South Carolina and it actually came in
last week um before there was a Kick the
Can on the road um moment in the
government um but it said with the
impending government shutdown how do I
as a government employee combat the
stress and anxiety of possibly not
getting paid but still being required to
show up for
work is that how that works yeah well
there's back pay so once they're back
they get the money but while you're
there it's not
happening which means they're missing
some
paychecks I've got my own thoughts on
that I'm the Sole Provider my third
daughter will be here in November we
have no savings and are in some debt all
right so I'm GNA answer this George
globally because it's super frustrating
for me
if I had let's say um we had I want to
put something into context for everybody
okay so when Co happened and we were
told you cannot go into the office Dave
and the operating board called that
emergency meeting if you remember that
and Dave said we have this much money in
the account this is how much cash this
company has on hand and we are a cash
only company this is how much we got
this is how much cash it takes to
operate and so you can see it's going to
get real tight real fast here is how
things will go number one if it gets
super tight I will not take a check me
the CEO and owner of this place number
two the operating board will not take a
check number three we will go into the
next run of Vice Presidents will not
take a check number four we may have to
look into like so he laid out the map
but in so doing he announced to the
whole company he transparently here's
what we got this is I want everybody on
the same page here but I go first I'm
the leader I go first when times are
good I win big when times are bad I go
first number two the next round of
leadership goes second the next round of
leadership goes third and to leaders if
y'all don't want to be a part of that
bye Felicia there's the door right but
here's how we're going to do this so ju
supposed that with a group of
senators who are sitting
I just have this picture George of them
in a kitty pool that they got at Walmart
for $5 and it's full of like bubbles and
they're throwing like Balloons with no
no water in them just like balloons at
each other it's a great mental picture
thank you for
that if it shuts down they still get
paid who doesn't get paid are these
employees who have kids trying to make
it so they're using these government
workers who keep this thing going for
all of us as fodder for their little
temper tanty games that they're trying
to play for an election coming up in a
year and it's so
disgusting how they use people like
Jason as fodder for their little their
little future re-election campaign just
pawns right awful game of chess and so
Jason if I worked for a guy if I had
gone to that meeting and Dave had said
listen here I'm getting mine if we shut
down if this shutdown actually happens
I'm getting paid my exx are getting paid
the rest of y'all we're going to cut the
low the the if the first in first out
whoever the last 100 employees are y'all
are fired after that I'm going to start
taking 20% from everybody's paychecks
right which happens across the country I
literally would go to my wife and say
we're out of here I don't trust that
person as a leader as a person of
Integrity as a stable operating leader
for the place that I that pays my
family's rent right and Jason a I want
to challenge you to begin to broaden
your Horizon and look bigger than this
particular job because you work for
people who will use you for their own
political gain and it cost them
literally nothing because they will
still get paid the Senators doing this
crap
playing tag with each other and then
here's what's gonna happen George gonna
play tag they're gonna play tag they're
gonna play tag and then something's
going to set off and I hate it but Jason
and I would explore something bigger and
then that so that's that's the big
30,000 foot view the reality is the
anxiety and stress is the alarm system
going off we may not have enough money
next month because our bosses are acting
like children and they won't actually
sit down and solve problems they just
want sound bites for their Twitter
account okay I'm going to always go
towards the alarm directly into it what
is this
mean George tell me if I'm crazy this
might mean I got to go to work until I
find some other job that will pay me
when I go every day instead of one
that's going to give me back pay if they
ever reopen and then you're going to
have to deliver pizzas at night to pay
the rent and you're going to have to get
up in the morning and drive Uber on your
way to your job that you're not getting
paid for and then you're going to have
to deliver pizza you're going have to to
figure out a way to get money and there
I wish there was another option to that
you can go borrow money and then you're
going to you're going to trap yourself
in a continued cycle of debt and false
security and whatever you're just going
to have to figure out a way to work on
Saturdays and Sundays and it's going to
suck but that's the real that's the
reality you face right yeah and what
this is he's in baby step two he's got a
baby on the way in November third
daughter and there's this impending
shutdown so we call this storm or stor
mode and it's the only time to pause
baby step paying off debt and just just
keep your minimum payments everything
else stack as much cash as possible
until you're out of the storm until mom
and baby are home until we know what the
heck is happening with this government
and so that might be 45 days that sounds
like about right if you wait just month
and a half get a side job keep working
stack all those uh into savings then
once the dust settles we can move
forward with the debt payoff that's what
I would do that would help me with my
anxiety and stress is some of the
reality pieces of it so and so let's
let's let's say out loud what our
fearless leaders are asking their
government employees to do because
they've only duct taped this thing
together for 45 days Jason I hate to
tell you this but I think today after
work you should stop by a local pizza
delivery place or get online and get
signed up for what some food delivery
service Uber eat door Dash inart Amazon
Flex go through that as quickly as
possible or possibly call Walmart and go
visit a Walmart in your suit and tie and
go in there and say hey can I sling
boxes from 400 p.m. until 11: p.m. and
for the next 45 days I want you to stack
cash and I want you to look at your wife
who's expecting third baby and say hey
we can't go out to eat because the
people running our country are so um
uninterested in solving some of these
problems they're more interested in
throwing crayons at each other um but we
got a my job is as a responsible adult
is to make sure we have food and shelter
so let's go ahead and do that and George
just it infuriates me because we watch
the news we watch these sound bites we
see these big things like oh my gosh
this and this and this side said that
and that side that said that and Jason
who's got a third baby on the way is the
guy who's at home and his wife who's on
other end of this other end of this
pingpong match between children who
can't figure it out it just it's so
infuriating with me man it just it's
disgusting at every single level on both
sides of the aisle everybody involved in
this thing just solve these problems and
let's figure something out like adults
and move on